like sometimes you watch red pill stuff  and it's very much like dooms day and  you're like very positive like you you  frame the wall in like a positive way  like i saw a piece of content from you  the other day that was saying like you  don't have to look at the wall as a bad  thing it just means you know it's how  you structure your life the wall is only  a problem if you're in denial about  aging as a woman yeah that's the only  the only time it's an issue or if all of  your content and character is solely  invested in your physique that's when  you struggle as a woman every  well-rounded woman i know isn't really  worried about the wall because they're  setting up their lives accordingly for  when they're going to be 40 50 60. and  you know for any woman that thinks that  the wall doesn't exist do you really  think that your grandma is as hot as she  was at 18. like i just want to know